And now, to you, Scoutmaster.
Hey, welcome back to...
Hey!
Hey, Bruce!
How you doing, bud?
Listen, something that I've been thinking about lately.
What's your motto?
Be prepared, son.
That's my motto.
Be prepared.
Really?
That's my motto, too.
Hey, this is podcast number 13.
Hey!
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmasters podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Thanks again for the feedback and the emails and things like that.
I'll have my contact information right at the end of the podcast.
This time around, in Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less, we're going to talk about mistakes and looking at mistakes.
Having a safe environment for Scouts to make mistakes and how to handle them when they do.
Then, I've got a story that is under the title, you know, this has got to be true because nobody would make this up.
Well, I made this one up.
But it's based on a lot of true stuff.
I hope you enjoy it.
And then our second of four installments on avoiding Eagle Scout trauma.
And that's followed by a Scoutmasters minute about the difference between tour guides and leaders.
I'm finishing up next week's show and I'm putting it together, next week's podcast.
And it involves an interview with author Richard Bennett, who wrote a book called Everything I Needed to Know I Learned in Boy Scouts.
And it's a tribute to his troop and his Scoutmaster from Irving, Texas in the mid to late 1960s.
And I had a wonderful time talking to Richard and we'll have the interview with him on next time around.
You're going to love the book.
The book is really, really good.
I really enjoyed it.
But we've got a lot to cover today, so let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
If you watch football, and I really don't.
And I'm not a big Giant fan, but I've seen some games over time.
Watch a football game and somebody fumbles the ball.
And they're frustrated and they're, you know, they're kind of angry and they're disappointed.
And I think I have seen, if I remember correctly, you know, even a big strapping NFL player just about reduced to tears over having messed up a play.
Have you seen that?
I've seen it.
And so, but, you know, their teammates get behind them and pat them on the back and dust them off and say, hey, we've got to get back out here and play.
So, you know, quit your crying and let's move on.
If big guys can be frustrated in that way, imagine what it is in the mind and the life of one of your youth leaders.
If he fumbles and he drops the ball.
It's a pretty humiliating experience.
Especially if you're a scout age boy.
Because you're very sensitive to what people think about you.
What your peers think about you.
What the adult leaders that you work with think about you.
And what the fellows who are younger than you think about you.
So if a youth leader drops the ball or fumbles something or forgets to do something, he will either own up to the problem and deal with it directly.
Which would be the best case scenario.
Hey, oh my gosh, I forgot to make that phone call.
Or I just got busy and I didn't do it.
I am sorry.
That is a pretty rare reaction.
Because it takes a lot of maturity and security to be able to just admit a mistake outright like that.
More often than not, they'll react in a couple of other ways.
They will hide the mistake until somebody else finds it.
Or until they get pressed on it.
They won't just come in and say,
Oh, oh, you know, oops, I blew it.
Nope.
They'll hide it until somebody else figures it out.
Then, they'll deny the responsibility or the importance of the task we're supposed to be doing.
And they'll make a lot of excuses and equivocations and things like that.
Making some kind of a leadership misstep, just not carrying out a responsibility,
is not as clear as fumbling a football.
I mean, you fumble a football, everybody sees it.
They see the ball on the ground and they say,
Ooh, he fumbled the ball.
But the result in the person's mind, I think, is just as dramatic.
And they feel bad.
And they feel frustrated.
And they know that they've let everybody down.
So what happens?
Well, as I said before,
If a football gets fumbled, the whole team jumps for it, right?
I mean, they don't stand there and point at the guy who fumbled the football and shake their fist at him and try and beat him up.
No.
I mean, they all jump for the ball.
And then afterwards, they dust the guy off and pat him on the back and say,
Oh, it's all right.
We'll get back at it.
And why do they do that?
Because they know if they were carrying the ball, it's just as easy for them to fumble.
That they're not immune from making a mistake.
Now, if the response to a fumble was that your team ostracized you and, you know, you got a sound beating,
Not many guys would want to carry a football under those conditions, would you think?
What about scouts?
If they make mistakes, if we find fault and punish them, we don't treat them with empathy,
and we don't dust them off and tell them to get back in the game,
they're not going to want a position of responsibility.
Now, I'll overhear somebody discussing the idea that,
Well, you know, we just can't get our older scouts to step up to responsible positions in the troop.
The way you handle a fumble or a mistake could have a lot to do with the willingness of your scouts to take on responsibilities.
If they watch you ostracize and, you know, figuratively beat up on a scout who's made a mistake of some kind,
they are not going to be interested in taking up a responsibility.
If we reply with empathy and encouragement,
they're going to be much more likely to take on those responsibilities.
So it would be a good idea to make sure that, within your troop,
you have a safe environment to make mistakes.
Now, I'm not saying that scouts don't need to be accountable.
We can accomplish that without dramatics or punishment or bad feelings.
This has to be the truth, folks,
because there is no way anyone could make this up.
All right, so, you know, you become a Boy Scout.
And then you're going to go on your first camping trip,
and you've got to patrol, and everything is cool,
and then you find out you've got to cook.
What?
You've got to cook?
Oh, yeah, the older guys say,
oh, it's the best part of the trip.
It's the most fun.
It's great.
You know, we can make anything that we want,
and then the entire world opens up around you,
and you start thinking of all the wonderful things that you can cook,
and you figure out that I'm going to make hunter stew.
Hunter stew.
It just, it sounds wonderful.
So, you find a recipe, and you make your list,
and you go to the grocery store,
and you buy all these unfamiliar things,
like chicken and potatoes and stuff like that.
I mean, things that, you know, you've seen around the house,
and you've seen maybe your mom or dad work with before,
but in your hands, there's something magical
and something new and exciting.
So, you smile as you go to sleep that night and think,
boy, the guys are going to be patting me on the back.
Maybe they'll buy me one of those big white chef's hats, you know,
after I make this hunter stew.
Oh, it's going to be grand.
Well, then you pack everything up,
and you get on the camp out and all that stuff,
and you're waiting all day, all day,
until it's time to prepare dinner.
You might even go back to the cooler
and kind of fiddle around with the stuff
and just make sure that it's all there
and everything's ready.
And then somebody says,
well, it's about time we start cooking dinner.
And so you turn around and bend down
and grab a bag of potatoes,
and you're about to hand them
to one of your fellow patrol members
and say, well, we need to peel these potatoes, guys.
And you look up, and they've disappeared.
They're all gone.
They found things to do.
One guy has decided that this is a good time
to do tree identification.
So he grabs his scout handbook
and two other patrol members,
and they head off into the woods.
They're going to, you know,
work on that tree identification thing
for second class there.
And then, you know,
you find out the other guys
needed to go use a little latrine.
It seems like they've been away
for an awfully long time.
But you look around,
and there's your buddy.
And he's going to help you build the fire
and get things going.
So you start about 4.30,
and then, oh, around 6.30 or so,
you slice some potatoes
into your hunter stew
that's not really bubbling yet
over the fire.
You know, the fire needs a little help.
Well, finally, the patrol leader
kind of figures out
that there's something wrong,
and he gets all the patrol members,
and now you have a roaring fire,
and it's built up around your pot there,
and your stew is boiling
and everything,
and it's only 7.30.
I mean, you've got plenty of time.
And so the water boils
and everything looks great,
and the, oh, my,
the aroma coming off of that stew.
Oh, it's just amazing.
Just amazing.
At around 8 o'clock,
after the fire is burned out
and the guys are running off
into the woods
to find more firewood
to reheat the stew,
you test a couple of pieces of potato,
and they're still hard as a rock.
Oh, well.
It'll only take another half hour or so.
You hope.
So the patrol finally gets desperate,
and they decide at 8.30,
you know, we're going to eat
because we're starving to death.
My God, we didn't know
this was going to take so long.
So you dish out the stew,
and everybody gets a big mess kit
full of stew,
and they all sit around,
and they're chomping on it,
and they have to saw at it hard
with a knife to break it up
and to get it into pieces
so that it will fit in their mouth,
and then you've got to chew on it
for 10 or 15 minutes
before you can get it down.
And everybody kind of looks at each other,
and you say,
well, how's the stew?
And they say,
eh, it's all right.
So you figure the next time,
the next time,
it's going to be some other sucker's time
to, you know,
buy the food and cook.
I'm not going to deal
with these guys anymore.
Oh, no.
I'm not going to mess around with them.
Go and work my heart out
and make stew for them,
and they don't even,
they don't even like it.
Now, secret is,
you don't really like it either.
You know,
salt and pepper would have been a good idea,
but of course,
you didn't bring any along.
And then,
then the light shines down from heaven,
and it comes into your mind
that there's something else in the cooler.
So you go to the cooler,
you grab that box full of popsicles.
They're a little soft,
but they're still good.
And everybody's been sawing,
and chewing,
and carrying on,
and trying to get that stew down
for the past half hour.
And they look at you,
and you have a box of popsicles in your hand,
and you hold them up,
and you triumphantly say,
hey, fellas,
it's dessert.
And now,
you're everybody's pal.
You're everybody's friend.
Ah,
camping
with scouts
and your patrol.
What could be better?
Have you ever wandered
lonely through the woods?
And everything that feels
just as it should.
You're part of a life there.
You're part of something good.
If you've ever wandered
lonely through the woods.
So this is the second installment
in our discussions
about Eagle Scout drama
and avoiding Eagle Scout drama.
And in the first one,
we talked about the idea that,
you know,
Scoutmasters have a tendency
to develop this
idealized standard
of what an Eagle Scout should be.
And we get frustrated
when we don't see that.
It is a key source
of drama
in this
becoming an Eagle Scout process.
What we need to understand
is what makes scouting different
from everything else.
And this is the way
that it's different.
And you forgive me,
but I'm getting up,
I'm getting up on my soapbox here
and I'm going to preach
just a little bit
because Baden-Powell
hit the nail on the head.
I mean,
he founded and envisioned
a movement
that would give everyone
the opportunity
to challenge
an achievement
based not on
a single standard
of performance,
but on a highly individualized
and internalized standard.
And what I'm saying
specifically
is this is a quote
from Baden-Powell's
Outlook.
It's a column
that he had
in a scouting magazine
and this is dated
in 1921.
Now listen to this carefully.
He says,
Our standard for badge earning,
as I have frequently said,
is not to attain
a certain level
of quality of work
as in school,
but in the amount
of effort exercised
by the individual candidate.
This brings
the most hopeless case
on a footing
of equal possibility
with his more brilliant
or better off brother.
We want to get them
all along
through cheery
self-development
from within
and not through
the imposition
of formal instruction
from without.
If we,
as scoutmasters,
can encourage scouts
to define
and internalize
and follow
a standard
of achievement,
we'll give them
a set of skills
that will immeasurably
enrich their lives
and their communities.
Yeah,
I gotta tell you,
it's frustrating.
Like a lot
of scoutmasters,
I was really frustrated
with the lack
of measurable numbers
in scouting.
And this is what I mean.
What is scout spirit?
What's that all about?
How do you figure
that one out?
What percentage
of meetings
or campouts
does a scout
have to attend
to be considered active?
What does active mean?
How do you apply
a measure
of effectiveness
to somebody's leadership?
Shouldn't you have
a form
and some numbers
and be able
to figure this out
so it's fair
all the way
across the board
and everybody
gets judged
on a single standard?
Well,
the numbers
are missing
from scouting
not because
somebody forgot
but for a very good reason.
Every scout
and every scout's
circumstances in life
are different.
Scouts
who are academically
talented
and scouts
who are poor students,
scouts from affluent families
and scouts
from families
who are not so affluent,
scouts with a whole lot
going for them
and scouts
with not very much
going for them,
they all become
Eagle Scouts.
There are no
Class A or Class B
Eagle Scouts.
When we understand
and embrace
the concept
of individual effort
evaluated by
an individualized standard,
we're going to
eliminate a lot of drama
not only from
the Eagle Scout process
but from our entire
experience in scouting.
You've got to ask
and it's a fair question,
can't you use
an individualized standard
to justify
just about anybody
becoming anything
and achieving
Eagle Scout?
Can't you use it
to justify
bad behavior
and poor performance
and indifference?
I mean,
how does a Scoutmaster
hold his scouts
accountable
if everybody
is just going
to advance anyway?
I mean,
what would be the point?
Well,
the answer is
really very simple
and it's going
to be in number three
of this four-part series
on avoiding Eagle Scout drama
so make sure to listen
to the next podcast.
That's right,
it's time
for a Scoutmaster's Minute.
A tour guide has a script.
They take their group,
they lead them through
a series of timed events,
they speak,
they're done.
A leader doesn't have a script,
they have a set of competencies
and skills,
they have a set of resources,
they take their group,
they lead them towards a goal.
They may get done
in a certain time,
it might take a little longer,
it might be a little shorter.
They'll probably have to
change strategies along the way,
they're not compelled
to stick to a script.
Something will come up,
some set of circumstances
will change,
it will demand they use
other resources
or other skills.
Ultimately though,
the group will reach the goal.
There's a big difference.
In Scouting,
if we take our youth leadership
and we just give them a script,
a set of predictable circumstances,
we tell them to walk through it,
kind of like a tour guide,
we've missed developing leadership.
We don't want to compel them.
Let's encourage them,
as leaders,
to take their group
towards a goal.
Let them define the goal.
They'll figure it out.
Give them some ideas.
Let them define a goal
and then watch.
When the circumstances change,
give them a little coaching.
Maybe you have to change
your strategy a little bit.
Maybe you have to
use some other resources
or skills you didn't plan on using.
And then watch them
get their group through
to the goal.
That's what we're really looking for
as Scout Masters.
It's not so much
training tour guides
as developing leaders.
Thanks for listening
to the Scout Master podcast.
Sure do appreciate
getting emails and things.
You can email me directly,
clarkgreen
at gmail.com.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N.
You can follow us
at scoutmasterblog.typepad.com.
Also, Scout Master blog
on Facebook
and Scout Master blog
on Twitter.
The Scout Master blog
and the Scout Master podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
by the Boy Scouts of America.
No.
Just a way to try
to help out a little bit
and have a little fun
along the way.
So, Sir Robert,
what would you like
to tell the nice people?
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Hmm.
My sentiments exactly.
Yes.
We'll talk to you again next time.
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Good luck to you.
Goodבע na Doo,
".
I did bragging every day,
but at this time,
take a look for your bestseller
.
You know what I'm really
going to callless
with this type of schedule
and it's still easy.
Well,
I wish you all
again next time.
It's the place
where the kind of
between Malise
has a great пол
and it's just
good time for him
and wonder